[Music]
you know 100% foolproof way to ruin any
outfit
scruffy shoes the holiday season why not
treat yourself to a pair of really nice
shoes there's even scientific studies
that prove you can accurately judge a
man's personality just by looking at his
shoes I know you think that really good
shoes are prohibitively expensive and
even cheap shoes can last you for a year
or two can't they
but high-quality shoes will last you for
10 even for 20 years okay they are
pricier to begin with because they're
handmade and of my children in some
sweatshop factory but by real
craftspeople who get paid a decent wage
let me show you something I bought these
here 15 years ago my first decent pair
and the Murray sold three times over the
years has spent 600 euros on them sounds
like a lot doesn't it but it's not it's
just three euros a month so for just 10
euros per month you can own three decent
pairs of shoes and here are the three
essentials you want first black cap toe
Oxford classic of classic absolutely
timeless for nearly every occasion
number two
Darby brogues why not in brown a bit
more the sporty side anyway by the way
do you know the difference between an
Oxford and a Derby the Derby has the
facing stitched on top of the shoe with
an Oxford it's sewn underneath number
three if you're too lazy to lace up long
straps also very elegant
then there's chelsea boots for the
winter
and loafers for the summer I hate
loafers the question is how do I
recognize a good quality shoe let's ask
a pro shall we you can just feel it
can't you one thing might be balanced
nothing is wobbling around you can trust
this shoe another thing the details my
grass eyelets for a gentleman's corner
at the heel and a third thing for a
business shoe is the leather sole the
hand stitching you can feel it so treat
yourself view it as a sustainable
investment because classics like these
never go out of style
you